as the verdict was read out Vladimir
karmorza listened without any visible
reaction
convicted of treason spreading false
information about Russia's armed forces
and cooperating with an undesirable
organization his lawyer said Kara morza
saw it as a verdict on the justness of
his cause
this is a terrible but very high
assessment of Vladimir's work as a
politician as a citizen this is how he
perceived this verdict when he heard it
25 years his self-esteem even went up he
realized he was doing everything right
as hundreds of journalists packed a room
where they watched the court proceedings
on screen reaction to the verdict came
in swiftly
Nobel Laureate Dimitri muratov who was a
witness in karamarza's case told Al
Jazeera it was part of a dangerous
pattern that's emerged in Russia since
the war in Ukraine began
sentences for political prisoners are
handed down in the same way they were
handed down during Stalin's time these
are huge sentences 25 years is the
lifetime of one generation of people
they want to take an entire generation
out of the lives of Russians who won't
meet politicians like karamurza the
longtime Kremlin critic was arrested
last April under new laws passed eight
days after Russia's Invasion restricting
any criticism of the country's Army the
Russian British former journalist and
politician is the latest of several of
President Putin's opponents to have been
arrested Kara morza played an important
role in persuading Western governments
to sanction Russian officials for
alleged human rights abuses and
Corruption
Vladimir caramurzo's attorney says
she'll be appealing this verdict arguing
that her client has had no previous
convictions and a health condition so he
will not be able to serve his term in a
maximum security facility 99 of cases in
Russian courts end with convictions
there was no expectation that this one
would be any different
dorsa chapari Al Jazeera Moscow